is to put all the pieces together and
ensure that nothing goes wrong that
actually starts months earlier for a
shot we begin working with the design
team
to decide on a concept that we want to
test
once that's decided then we work with
our colleagues in Target fabrication and
the laser science in order to bring
those pieces of the experiment in
and then a few days before the shot it's
handed off to the operations Crews on
the facility we work with them to
actually execute the experiment because
they're the ones who are actually
Hands-On in the facility making this a
reality
the shot goes off it takes only a few
billionths of a second and so we need an
Exquisite Suite of Diagnostics to
measure what happened
and with those measurements we can then
increase our understanding of the
particular experiment
I want to emphasize that
each experiment we do is building on 60
years of work in this field and more
than a decade on nif itself
so we use that previous understanding in
order to field design or experiments
each experiment then contributes to the
overall knowledge both these main Fusion
ignition shots and also experiments that
we do with specialized configurations
and specialized Diagnostics all building
the understanding that allows us to make
progress
all that work led up to a moment just
after 1am last Monday when we took a
shot
and we started to see
um
hopefully that's uh not representative
but we took a shot just after 1am last
Monday and as the data started to come
in we saw the first indications that
we'd produced more Fusion energy than
the laser input and so I'm very excited
to be here on behalf of the experimental
team and with my colleagues on behalf of
the entire nif team to discuss it with
you
um so good good morning I'm Annie
kreitzer I'm the principal designer for
the experiment and the campaign and also
team lead for integrated modeling of
these experiments and I'm here to
represent the entire design team so the
role of a designer is to define the
input conditions to the experiment to
achieve the desired plasma conditions
and that includes the target geometry
Dimensions materials Etc as well as a
laser pulse so we don't just smack the
target with all the laser energy all at
once we Define very specific Powers at
very specific times to achieve the
desired conditions and we do this using
a variety of tools including complex
plasma physics simulations analytical
models and we Benchmark them against
experimental data
um so the ultimate goal as Alex
mentioned is uh to create a design that
can reach the extreme conditions
required for Fusion ignition on a nif
and in doing so we were able to reach
pressures more than two times the center
of the sun on the last experiment and
about 150 million degrees
and this requires a great deal of
finesse and design optimization to reach
these conditions as well as continual
learning over the many years of designs
and results that we've collected at nif
and specifically there were two design
changes that were made leading up to the
most recent result that fed into it so
this most recent result is part of a new
campaign or a new effort to make use of
the new laser capability that JM will
talk about next and that is making the
capsule that holds the Fusion fuel a
little bit thicker and that does two
things that gives us more margin for
achieving ignition when we have
non-optimal Fielding conditions as well
as it lets us burn up more of the DT
Fusion fuel so the first experiment in
this campaign was performed in September
and the the experiment we're talking
about today made intentional design
changes from the September shot also to
improve the symmetry of the implosion
and with that I'm happy to be here and
to take questions and very excited about
our team's work on this
all right good morning I'm Jean-Michel
de Nicola chief engineer for nif laser
systems I'm representing the team of
technician engineer and scientists who
design build operate and improve this
unique laser facility
and together our team is standing on the
shoulder of multiple generation of
optical material and Laser physicists
who design and optimized ever increasing
performance in terms of the laser
delivery following the seminal paper
from John Nichols Livermore who
basically lay down the concept for
nuclear fusion using lasers
however we also want to acknowledge
numerous collaborators and other
National Labs University industry as
well as International partners and of
course continued support from doe and
NSA in Congress for this Mission so
important for National Security
thanks to outstanding science and
technology and our team Livermore with
collaborator made the impossible
possible
the knife laser is the largest laser in
the world
it has the size of three football fields
and it delivers an energy in excess of 2
million joules with a peak power of 500
trillion Watts
for a very short amount of time we are
talking only about a few billionth of a
second it exceeds the entire grid U.S
power grid
um the laser however achieving the
ignition however requires more than
Brute Force as any described there are
extremely fine tunings that needs to be
performed to match the condition for
ignition
Precision has been our Focus for the
last few years and we have been
delivering more symmetric implosion and
more reproducible experiments
and in addition thanks to the continue
investment from the nation we have been
able to deliver eight percent more
energy on the experiments last week
compared to the one last year
um it it goes along with additional
efforts that will be brought during the
summer and in Us in next summer we'll be
able to design experiments and field
shots with additional eight percent of
laser energy providing more margins for
ignition
in the future with a sustainment and
upgrade investment the new laser could
produce even higher energies and Power
and give the promise to larger Target
gains that would be enabling additional
extreme conditions for science-based
stockpiles to our chip program and
maintain the United States of America
leadership in this field I'll pass it
over to Michael
morning I am Michael staterman I am the
program manager for Target fabrication
at Livermore I'm here to present a team
of over 100 members that is responsible
for making almost all Targets shot on
nif and that comprises members of
general atomics of diamond materials in
Germany and of Lawrence Livermore
the most important component that we
deliver for Fusion targets is the fuel
capsule fuel capsule is a BB Point sized
shell made of diamond that needs to be
as perfect as possible we've been
working over the last 16 years on
continuously improving the quality of
these shells to get to the state where
we are today and in turn that effort has
been based on Decades of Prior capsule
development activities that have been
done at Livermore elsewhere
today's shells are almost perfectly
round they're 100 times smoother than a
mirror and they have a tiny tube
attached to them that's about a 50th the
diameter of a hair
to which the fuel is filled into the
shell
as you can imagine Perfection is really
hard and so we've yet to get there we
still have tiny flaws on our shells
smaller than bacteria that could be for
example Pits on the surface or holes in
the wall
despite their small size these flaws
still have the potential to affect the
experiment so not only do we make the
shells but we also characterize the
shells and make sure and share the
results with our colleagues so that we
can select the best shell for each
experiment
how strongly an experiment is affected
by the flaws depends on the design input
that Annie was talking about
and it looks like the result from Monday
is a more robust design that is less
affected this is very encouraging for us
because we know that the shell that we
shot had flaws in it and this gives us
confidence that we can make shells of
equal quality even better quality in the
future that will be able to reproduce
this experiment or even improve on it
yeah so with that I'll pass it on target
thanks my name is Arthur pack I'm the
team lead for stagnation science which
is really focused on trying to
understand how to create the conditions
to achieve ignition at the nif
so I'm responsible for coordinating the
portfolio of integrated experiments so
it's been pursuing ignition as well as
overseeing the analysis groups that take
these observations we get from the
experiments and try to understand the
conditions of the fusion plasma and this
has been really critically important to
understand these conditions as I'll talk
about and it's really been enabled by
sort of state-of-the-art Diagnostics
Optical x-ray nuclear Diagnostics that
have been developed over Decades of work
by an exceptional team of Engineers and
scientists from Lawrence Livermore and
from other National Laboratories in the
U.S the UK and France in addition with
major contributions from our domestic
and international academic and Industry
partners
so for each experiment we field over 50
scientific measurements to diagnose key
quantities of the reacting fusion plasma
such as the temperature the Fusion
Energy yield the duration over which
this occurs
and to give you a sense of scale and
just how remarkable these you know these
these Diagnostics are the plasma we're
trying to measure is uh is a tenth of a
millimeter in diameter so that's the
thickness of a strand or two of human
hair as was mentioned the temperatures
of these plasmas are over 100 million
degrees so that's 10 times hotter than
the center of the sun and the entire
reactions occur in a fraction of a
nanosecond so that's about a billion
times faster than you can blink your eye
and then as Alex mentioned we're only
able to get these great measurements due
to the sort of tireless work of
technicians and operators who field them
at the facility and and allow us to get
these these these amazing observations
to help us understand what's going on
and these observations have been really
critical for our progress so they've
they've helped to identify quantify and
mitigate degradations or loss mechanisms
which have impeded our progress they
allow us to test hypotheses and design
changes to understand what are the
sensitivities of the system and so I'm
here today on behalf of these diagnostic
groups to help answer any questions and
talk about what we can learn from these
experiments
thanks
good morning my name is Tammy Ma and I
am the lead for the Lawrence Livermore
institutional initiative in inertial
Fusion Energy or what we call Ife
developing an economically attractive
approach to Fusion Energy is a grand
scientific and engineering challenge
without a doubt it will be a Monumental
undertaking
however the potential benefits are
enormous
clean
carbon free abundance
reliable energy capable of meeting the
world's energy demands and furthermore
providing for the energy sovereignty and
energy security of the U.S
as the secretary mentioned earlier today
this spring the White House hosted a
summit announcing a bold decadal vision
for Fusion Energy building on great
advances we had in both inertial and
magnetic confinement Fusion
these recent results on the nif are the
first time in a laboratory anywhere on
Earth we were able to demonstrate more
energy coming out of a fusion reaction
than was put in
this lays the groundwork it is it
demonstrates the basic scientific
feasibility of inertial Fusion Energy
and sets the road map for us to move
forward to even higher gains and towards
Fusion pilot plants in the coming
decades
the department of energy office of
Fusion Energy Sciences recently
commissioned a basic research needs
report in inertial Fusion Energy
this report will help lay out the
framework for a new Ife program here in
the U.S and that report should be coming
out imminently
such a program will inevitably
inevitably require participation from
across the community both the public
sector but the private sector as well so
of course new Fusion startup companies
their investors National Labs
universities Academia public utilities
and more
we look forward to working with the
Department of energy to leverage and
capitalize on these great results for a
Fusion Energy Future
time is now
and I will hand it back to mark
thanks Tim
um so we're going to ask each each
panelist a question here and then we'll
open it up to the floor
um Annie this experiment improved on on
an experiment as you mentioned that we
had done in September of 2022 and it was
a modified design from the one in August
of 2021
can you explain how you used physics
insights and simulations to make changes
in the design for this recent experiment
relations to design many aspects of our
implosions however we know that there's
areas of parameter space where we might
not be as predictive so we have
developed Playbook experimental
playbooks and analytical models and I
used a combination our design team used
a combination of both to make the
adjustment from September going into
this latest experiment there was two
sort of different flavors of symmetry
adjustments that were made one is during
sort of the second half of the laser
time history and one is during the first
half of the laser time history during
the second half of the laser time
history we transferred more energy
between laser beams to control the
symmetry so that's actually quite a
useful tool and if you haven't heard
about it it's really awesome you can
move energy between beams and control
symmetry that way in doing so you have
to go back and re-adjust the Symmetry
during the first half of the laser pulse
and we did that but we also did that
making an additional adjustment with
improved models Based on data that were
collected just in the last few months so
in that piece we really do rely on our
models to Benchmark against tuning data
and then extrapolate out to the design
space and just for perspective we're
talking about compressing something the
size of a basketball down to the size of
a key controlling that compression
symmetry to about one percent in in
drive and also the final symmetry to
just a few percent so it's quite a
challenging problem and we have great
tools to get there
thanks Annie
uh John Michelle for many years the
maximum laser energy on nif was 1.9
megajoules but in this experiment you
turn the laser up to 2.05 megajoules
how did you and your team make sure that
this would be safe to operate the laser
at these higher higher laser Energies
thank you Mark first of all I would like
to point out that the national ignition
facility is one of the first generation
of the inertial confinement Fusion to
meet and exceed its requirement so it's
uh it's by itself quite a Grand
Challenge to do that because those laser
architectures are extremely complex and
our Marvel of engineering and Laser
physics and nonlinear Optics
um second uh since the commissioning of
the national ignition facility we have
continuously increased the energy and
power over you know a few years to make
sure that we were obtaining the regime
where ignition experiment could take
place in favorable conditions
in parallel there was a tremendous
amount of investment in terms of Optics
Science and Technology as well as laser
physics to have Optics that would be
higher performance compared to the
previous generation and we gained orders
of magnitude compared to previous
generation no questions about it we
perform also a lot of work trying to
control the the shape of the laser in
space and time to make sure we can
transmit the maximum throughput through
the Optics with maximum reliability last
but not least we also figured out that
some of the debris are migrating back
into the laser from the target
experiment and ignition when it takes
place debris are transported back you
know near the Optics and you know
Finding and mitigating those debris
sources was also a key instrument so
very minor modification to the laser
architecture and and we published a
paper in 2019 in nuclear fusion if you
want more detail about that
thanks Jim uh Alex many many elements
have to come together to enable a
successful nif experiment we need a good
Target a cryogenic ice layer we need the
lasers to be specified and we need to
make sure the Diagnostics are going to
be taking pictures at the right time so
how did you prepare for this experiment
knowing it had the potential to be a
really exciting shot
yeah so one of the things that's so
challenging with these experiments is
that any one thing going wrong can be
enough to prevent ignition so everything
has to be right and so we really have to
sweat the small stuff
to kind of give you a sense for that
Annie discussed our tuning of the
symmetry we had a debate over a laser
setting equivalent to five trillionths
of a meter going into this experiment we
had a discussion with the laser science
team over timing discrepancies of 25
trillionths of a second
with the target each Target we look at
all of the flaws that Michael was
describing that are the size of a
bacteria to decide if they're acceptable
or not
they then grow a cryogenic DTI Slayer
which has the same sorts of requirements
bacteria size defects can be problematic
and then we're setting up the
Diagnostics where small timing errors
you know a billionth of a second would
be an
eternity for us in this experiment we're
trying to image something that's the
brightest thing on Earth for 100
trillionths of a second and so getting
all that right is a team effort going
through an intense review process
thanks
art how do we know this experiment past
the threshold of ignition and got more
Fusion Energy out than laser energy in
um for the first time in history
yeah thanks so in these experiments we
use deuterium and tritium as our Fusion
fuel which are isotopes of hydrogen and
when these two ions fuse they release a
helium ion or an alpha particle and a
neutron and they're released with a very
well known energies now the alpha
particle it stays in the plasma further
heating it leading to more Fusion
reactions while the neutrons largely
escape and so if we can measure the
number of escaping neutrons then we know
how many reactions took place and then
we just multiply the number of reactions
by the energy released for each fusion
and that's how we measure the Fusion
Energy so in this experiment to get a
Target gain one we used 2.05 megajoules
of laser energy so to exceed one we need
to make at least that much Fusion Energy
so the way we we measure the number of
neutrons we do that multiple ways using
independent Diagnostics but one of the
methods we use is to place a high Purity
metal sample close to the to the
reactions that gets irradiated by the
escaping neutrons and becomes
Radioactive
so the unstable States in this foil will
then Decay and because we know very well
the rate of activation and Decay we can
then measure how many neutrons went
through that foil and what the total
number of neutrons were and how much
Fusion Energy was released we have other
methods so another independent method is
to turn the escaping neutrons into a
Charged particle Spectrum disperse that
using a magnetic spectrometer and sweep
that onto a piece of film and so we can
actually measure the number of sort of
incident neutrons directly so all these
different methods give us a very very
high confidence that we produced 3.15
megajoules of Fusion Energy which
corresponds to a gain of roughly one and
a half so that's how we know
thanks sir
so Michael you talked about the targets
they were incredible marvels of
engineering and Manufacturing can you
briefly describe how you've been working
to actually make them even better the
thin spherical diamond shells that
contain the Fusion fuel sure Mark so the
main thing the main problem that we have
right now with getting perfect capsules
are small flaws
and so to be able to improve on the
flaws the first thing that we have to be
able to do is actually see them measure
them count them and quantify how many of
the flaws are on a shell
the primary tool that we use today to
characterize a shell is computer x-ray
tomography
extratermography generates a lot of data
and in the past it is required trained
experts a lot of time to go through
these images and basically find the
needle in the haystack
so now what we're working on is software
that helps us in this process and
hopefully will be more accurate than a
human in the longer run that will help
us quantify exactly to see how many
flaws there are how many how big they
are and whether when we're making a
change to the deposition to the
fabrication process where that actually
improves the number of flaws in their
size
so that's the characterization part on
the actual Improvement of the material
we are working very closely with our
collaborators in Germany at Dime
materials to look at the fabrication
conditions we're working as a team using
the others capabilities as a reference
to our own so that we can isolate the
problem to machine operation or
surroundings and this process has been
very fruitful for narrowing down a set
of conditions that has allowed us to
improve the target Beyond where we are
today
thanks Michael
okay Tammy
um so to power the laser for this
experiment the two to get that 2.05
megajoules we had to pull about 300
megajoules from the grid
um and and then we got out 3.15
megajoules of Fusion Energy right so so
why do we think it's possible to turn
this into an energy source in the future
and thank you Mark
the nif is a scientific demonstration
facility and when we built the nif the
considerations that you have to build
that facility are a little bit different
than if you're going to build a fusion
power plant so for example maximizing
the efficiency of every single component
is not necessarily the most important
thing and so for example the wall plug
efficiency of the laser was not
necessarily a very important requirement
for this science facility
however
um as Kim alluded to the nif is now over
20 years old and the technology inside
the nif is 80s 90s technology and things
that progressed quite a lot since then
we have new laser architectures that can
not only run at rep rate but are far
more efficient up to something around 20
wall plug efficiency there's also been
enormous advancements in Target
fabrication new materials computation
and simulations the application of
machine learning so it's a really
exciting time because we get to
incorporate all of these emerging
Technologies with this new scientific
understanding that we've developed to
really push towards inertial Fusion
Energy
and I'll also note
perseverance it took us to get here as
has been mentioned it's been 60 years
since ignition was first dreamed of
using lasers and it's really a testament
to the perseverance dedication of the
folks that made this happen
it also means we have the perseverance
to get diffusion energy on the grid
thanks Tim and thanks panel and then now
we're going to open it up to questions
uh
a round of applause for our panelists
[Applause]
testing all right hi everybody I'm nnsa
public affairs deputy director Shila
Hassan I want to thank those of you who
stayed for this more technical
discussion with the folks that actually
made this happen
um it's a very exciting day for nnsa so
we're going to start the Q a portion we
have a little bit more time uh with
media so if there are any media folks
who came late and need to move up this
is where we have media seated just to
make sure you get your questions in and
my colleague Jeremy will be there on the
other side to get a mic if you're a
little too far and feel like you need to
reach so if you could please state your
name and your outlet before your
question otherwise I will remind you
hey it's Ariana from Bloomberg uh what
was the cost of the targets you're using
uh and also what fraction of the Fusion
fuel was actually converted to energy
during the shot thank you
I'm going to take the uh I'm happy to
jump in Michael you want to um I think
the way to think of the targets is how
long does it take for someone to build
them right because the predominant cost
is the the labor of the people
um and so they take months to build
right uh well if you so the the
components that comprise a Target take a
variety of different times to make the
actual assembly of the Target only takes
about two weeks to make the fuel capsule
ever makes it takes seven months from
the Inception of what you want to the
delivery of the capsule
the targets that we are using today are
designed for science right they're
designed to be flexible so that we can
reconfigure them as we want to learn
different things and they're designed to
be able to see what's going on
so these targets are not designed for a
Fusion Energy
no I don't think it's it's kind of like
we're sized we have a staff that can
produce the targets we need per year for
on nif and so uh it's really about a
Workforce more than a dollar per Target
the components the actual amount of gold
or
carbon or whatever are actually really
really cheap right I mean the the actual
cost of the materials and the targets is
next to nothing it's it's all the labor
that goes into it that makes it uh um
time consuming
to answer the second part of your
question it was about four percent of
the DT that was burned on the shot
well thanks I I often talk about
how special the National Laboratories
are because we do team science
and there's no better example of that
than what we just heard from you but I'm
guessing maybe you didn't come expecting
to do exactly what just happened so I'd
be very interested in just like short
stories about Why'd You Come and why do
you stay
at the lab thank you
I think I can uh I can give a quick
answer to that so I actually toured nif
while it was under construction as an
undergraduate and so seeing the scale of
what was possible at the National
Laboratories
um
is what drew me in as well as being able
to see you know the ability to do great
science that has an actual impact on
National Security and energy
applications and so yeah I hope that
anyone watching who's inspired by this
current moment comes to work with us in
the future and take this to the next
level
yeah and I actually have a very similar
story so you might notice a trend here I
came as an undergraduate in 2004 and I
saw nif and I thought this is a once in
a lifetime opportunity to be part of
this large interdisciplinary teams
working together Grand Challenge on
problems that move Humanity forward and
are so important for the nation also
it's just fun to tell your friends you
shoot big losers and my dad really liked
it as well so
all right we've got one question over
here
hi Michael greschko National Geographic
thank you all for being here and
congratulations
um what time on December 5th did the
shot occur and for each of you in the
minutes and hours after that how did you
first
learn that this shot was special
I can start with that so the shot went
off I believe at 103 a.m last Monday
um and so I was up to look at the data
and as the data started to come in we
started to see some you know indications
that this had happened and one of the
first things I did was call one of the
diagnostic experts to to double check
the data and we kind of went from there
so I had vivid dreams of all possible
outcomes from the shotness always
happens before a shot from like complete
success to utter failure and then I woke
up thankfully Alex had sent me a message
so by the time I woke up I saw that it
wasn't a failure and um and then of
course I start emailing you're texting
you right away and
um yeah so just amazing feeling of you
start looking at you see one Diagnostic
and you think well maybe that's not real
and then you start to see more and more
Diagnostics rolling in pointing to the
same thing and it was just a
great feeling
so for the laser team the the work
started earlier in the night because we
had to check and make sure during the
preparation stages of the experiment
were on track to a successful delivery
so numerous phone calls emails checking
of the results real time uh giving the
green light to proceed and then the
relief when we see the result in the
laser didn't screw up the experiment
that was relief number one and then we
start to receive the text with potential
yields and that's uh you know
Eureka and Euro movements
well for Target fabrication our work
usually ends somewhere about a week
before the shot when we deliver the
target to the facility we had high hopes
for this one so I was checking email as
soon as I woke up to see how the shot
did and was very excited about the
numbers that I saw
yeah so um as Annie mentioned
um we're building off of Prior
experiments and um
you know we had a good reason to be
optimistic for this experiment so I was
very keyed in and curious
um but as I started going later and
later I you know got to get the kids up
in the morning so okay I'm gonna I'm
gonna go to bed but uh I woke up at
three in the morning just out of sleep
and I went to check my email and I saw
the number and of course I I'd done the
math before the experiment so I knew
what number I I wanted to see for
getting greater than one and so the
preliminary data came out and I was like
holy smokes so that's how I sort of and
then I went back to bed or tried to go
back to bed which was
um I actually didn't find out until the
next morning I was at the airport at SFO
about to board a plane to come to DC
actually to attend the fusion power
Associates meeting which is an annual
meeting where we have Fusion leaders
coming together to really work together
on how to push forward Fusion Energy but
anyways I got I got a call from my boss
saying I think we got ignition
and I uh I burst into tears
and I was jumping up and down in the
waiting area the crazy person
um and uh yeah the tears were streaming
down my face after all these years every
time I walk into the national engagement
facility I still get goosebumps and so
it is a wonderful place to work and I'm
so proud of this team
thank you all
James Reardon Science News Magazine it
since the ignition uh the prior one that
was an important event have there been
events like this that have been failures
that have been disappointments and why
on Earth would you do it at 1am is there
a technical reason
yeah so um you know following uh last
last year's experiment we tried to
repeat that Experiment three or four
times and what we learned from those
experiments was that this design was
still very sensitive to the Target
defects
that were present and so we were able to
quantify the impact and understand you
know the origin of these defects and so
knowing that we we went for improved
designs to make ourselves more robust we
use that knowledge to try to pick the
best capsules to minimize the impact and
so um that that's why what led us to to
this to this event here and why 1am so
nif runs 24 7. so to grow these ice
layers it's a multi-day process and so
it's not fully deterministic so you'll
try it will fail you'll try to grow
again and so it just happens that the
shot cycle goes that way and that we
take the shot when we're ready to take
the shot so
uh James Osborne Houston Chronicle
um
there's two Tech you know two Fusion
Technologies magnetic confinement and
inertial
um does this can you sort of explain
where your breakthrough
does that does that sort of put inertial
at the Forefront now is that is that the
technology you know Society is going to
pursue or does it have implications for
magnetic that you know might allow that
to continue
um I think it was implied earlier that
magnet had sort of seen more advances of
late
um obviously though this is the big
breakthrough so if somebody could sort
of explain that thank you yeah
absolutely
um there's there's definitely pros and
cons for each different approach
um and there's different technology
developments that need to occur and so
uh both magnetic fusion and inertial
have made great advances in the past
couple of years there's also been
enormous private sector investment
actually more on the magnetic side than
the inertial side in recent years I
think what we've been able to
demonstrate on the nif is a burning
plasma we've gotten gain however like
Kim alluded to
we're a little bit farther behind in
some of the technology developments
because that's just not what we've been
focused on the past few years that being
said there's a lot of different
commonalities there's a lot of
commonalities between the two where we
can learn from each other there's a
burning plasma physics Materials Science
reactor engineering and we're very
supportive of each other in this
community Unity a win for either
inertial or magnetic confinement is a
win for all of us and we really just
want to see Fusion Energy happen
and the point is though that there are
different technological risks for both
of them right now Fusion is so
incredibly impactful and important for
humankind that what we really want to do
is maximize the potential Pathways to
success so we want to carry these
different approaches and and see what
will really work
uh could you give us your vision of what
a commercial
Fusion plan would look like using uh
this technology
I jumped ahead a couple of decades
what what uh what might this uh
production of energy look like
um so right now there are a number of
different approaches to
Target physics that could actually get
us to High Gain high margin all of those
have slightly different drivers so for
what we're doing on the nif we use high
energy lasers but there are designs
using heavy ions
pulse power
et cetera Etc
and there's been a number of different
integrated studies to try to pull all of
this together really where we are right
now is at a Divergent Point we've been
very lucky to be able to leverage the
work that the nnsa has done for inertial
confinement Fusion but if we want to get
serious about Ife we are at a point
where we need to invest in those
Technologies we need to figure out what
that integrated system looks like
because the target like like Michael
said is complex it takes a long time to
build
um and what we need for a power plant it
has to be simple it has to be high
volume it needs to be robust and there
are trade-offs if you can get to higher
gain with your target you can turn down
your laser energy or your laser
efficiency a little bit there are
decisions to be made about the materials
that you would use for your reactor
those would impact Your Design as well
so what we're doing now with the
Department of energy is actually
embarking on doing these integrated
system studies again with our best known
information about technology as it's
evolved today and to figure out where
the the biggest gaps are where we need
to invest where we need to buy down risk
and that will be an ongoing showing
activity for for quite a few years but
with this bold decadal Vision we are
really trying to accelerate and put
together these designs to see what is
the the most viable feasible design and
all come together to work on it
hi Dave naturop your fed scoop the
director mentioned earlier that machine
learning played a key role in sort of
the in-between between the thresh
reaching the threshold to ignition and
then this latest test so I'm curious uh
how I have advances in machine learning
and Computing helped you in your work
and how do you anticipate they might
help you moving forward
yeah I can take that question
um so we have made quite a bit of
advances in our machine learning models
to kind of tie together our complex
radiation hydrodynamic simulations with
the experimental data and learning
um specifically going between the August
8th 2021 experiment and this this latest
experiment we used it more for the
predictability phase versus the design
phase for the for this change so for
this change we sort of used our
traditional design methods of you know
not running thousands of simulations but
then we fed the the design to the team
that the cogsim machine learning team
and had them have them do an analysis of
the design and they did find that it had
a higher probability of achieving gain
of one
so uh with with the cogson models we're
able to look at uh more if the design is
more robust to some of the issues that
we had been having last year
thanks Annie now I believe we have time
for one or two more questions so before
we go back to Nat Geo
uh David Crandall retired from the
Department of energy where I spent 30
years in most of it related to Fusion
and most of it related to nif
the target
the target for 08 0821 the physics
ignition shot was deemed to be the most
pure Target you ever shot
how did this one compare
um yes as you mentioned the target for
210808 was probably the most pristine
shell that we've ever had it even
compared favorably to the other shells
in the batch as we learned later on as
we reanalyze the data for all those
shells this target here had a
substantial number of flaws compared to
that one specifically at higher it has
tungsten inclusions in a large number
all right time for our final question
uh James Reardon Science News Magazine
um so this experiment um
is specifically interested in in the in
the search for ignition but most of your
research at is is focused on stockpile
stewardship is it is it not and in that
case what fraction is dedicated to this
sort of research what fraction is
dedicated to stockpile stewardship and
do these sorts of shots have any
important information in them for
stockpile stewardship
sure I'm happy to take that one so the
ignition work we're doing is for
stockpile stewardship right our
thermonuclear weapons have Fusion
ignition uh that takes place in our
weapons and so studying Fusion ignition
is something we do to support the
stockpile stewardship program in
addition Fusion ignition creates these
very extreme environments that we have
no other way to access on Earth and in
fact in this experiment
for the first time ever we were able to
put some samples of materials that are
important for our future stockpile
modernization efforts that are going on
at Lawrence Civil War today in very
close to this intense Neutron burst and
then see how did they respond to that
intense new tremper so we're actually
using the output from these really cool
science experiments uh and which we're
also trying to understand we're also
using it to actually test materials for
stewardship applications but to your
other question
roughly speaking about 15 percent of the
experiments we do on nif are indirect
Drive experiments of the type that this
experiment was we do another roughly 15
percent that are other types of fusion
experiments inertial confinement Fusion
but using different approaches and then
the rest of them look at things like the
behavior of materials and high pressures
and getting data that's important to use
in our simulations for our nuclear
weapons understanding the behavior of
radiation and very complex environments
and geometries understanding how
hydrodynamic plasmas mix at very high
temperatures all of those things help us
Benchmark our simulation tools learn new
things about how matter behaves in these
really extreme conditions and underpins
the confidence we have in in our
deterrent
well thank you
how many questions do I get to ask as
many as you want well this is this is
really exciting my understanding was
that the experiment in
2021 was a little unexpected result
which was really good news and then it
was kind of hard to repeat that result
so was it more the Target and something
that Annie brought up that I hadn't been
aware of is the the time history of the
of the laser pulses is also important so
uh first question is what's what's more
dominant the the time history or the
target uh and a question for Arthur how
many orders of magnitude of neutron
flux do you have to monitor to get a
full picture
so I I can answer the the last question
first perhaps so you know as Alex
pointed out you know many things have to
happen
um have to go right basically for for
these experiments to really reach very
very high yields and gains so we have to
set up our Diagnostics to capture that
event but we also have to set up the
Diagnostics to capture lower orders of
magnitude so that if it doesn't go right
we understand what happened what was the
failure mechanism so we can fix it in
the future and so you know right now I
think we have something like three
orders or so of dynamic range that we
can measure so we so we have predictions
of how we set up the Diagnostics we try
to go above and below to make sure we we
get good measurements does that answer
your question yeah
yeah so I can take a crack at the other
one
um so I'm going into 210808 or August
8th of 2021 experiment we predicted
about half the yield increase that we
got we got about eight times the yield
increase and we predicted about four
times and the reason for that is because
we had improved the capsule quality like
was mentioned earlier so going into the
pre-shot prediction we're assuming the
same capsule quality with some other
design changes that were being made we
did perform a set of experiments after
that to try to piece apart which is
quality and which is the other design
changes and it was pretty consistent
with that sort of split between the two
following that experiment we haven't
been able to replicate the same capsule
quality and that is a main driver
because these defects are extremely
difficult to model and predict it's been
a main driver in the performance as well
as the predictability so then the
thought was to to try to design our way
around some of these stringent
requirements
and what was the other part of your
question the time history yeah thanks
yeah thank you
um so the time history there's different
forms of asymmetries and the one that
I'm talking about the change that was
made between September and this most
recent experiment was a slightly
different type of that's an intrinsic
symmetry correction during the repeat
experiments we did have two experiments
that had an anomalous laser deviation
which is is a mode one so that means for
example if the laser delivered
differently on top versus bottom that
would push the implosion in One
Direction so something that's not
designed or expected that did impact two
of those experiments but ever since then
we've been quite good and maybe JM can
talk about the improvements made there
that that hasn't been as big of an issue
yeah I can elaborate if you like
we basically are
um in the process of modernizing the the
what we call the front end of the laser
which is based on the fiber optics
technology
um the nif laser was first commissioned
at low level in 2001 so this part of the
laser was literally 20 year old and as
you can imagine in Telecom industry over
20 years there has been many revolutions
and so we were able to catch up and
capitalize on the latest Technologies to
improve this delivery
all right time for our final question I
think
here
um James Osborne Houston Chronicle again
um I think you've probably answered this
but maybe just for the Layman about
among us um so if the shell quality
wasn't as
clean on this experiment What What In
fact you made the difference were you
were able to achieve this breakthrough
this time
what what what do you what do you
attribute it to yeah so um the the speed
chart basically the same capsule quality
in September so that part remained
constant between the two experiments and
in September we achieved about 1.22
megajoules
um so being able to First achieve
megajoule yields again with worse
capsule quality than August 8th 2021
that was the first step and that was
attributed to the the laser enhanced
laser capability and the design change
of the thicker Target
and then moving between September and
the most recent experiment the only
changes to the input conditions were to
improve this intrinsic low mode
asymmetry so make the implosion more
symmetric as it's coming in you can
better couple your driver energy to the
hot the hot plasma
all right I'd like to thank everyone for
coming and I'd like to thank Dr Hermann
and the panel for taking time to share
this amazing achieval bus after what
must be a whirlwind week one more round
of applause please
[Applause]
and with that that concludes our nif
press conference event thank you for
coming